salses xiii tellement quand tu trembles
il faut que tous et de détente tu n'as
pas besoin d'être autant speed comme ça
tu trembles
est-ce que tu prends du coq hyperactif
en république dominicaine
la coque n'est pas loin mec j'ai juste
une question pourquoi tu trembles a
buzzé thieulin tremblante de ouf sûreté
vidéo tu trembles toujours beaucoup je
pense que tu dois avoir des tremblement
essentiel où la magie de par kingson oui
je précise les maladies exprès pour
éviter les moqueries de ton tremblements
après je me trompe sur menthon sujet
tuer ce cocaïne ou quoi surexcité le mec
c'est le coca cola on dirait par kingson
quoi mec c'est moi où tu te rendes de
ouf
[Musique]
bon
il faut qu'on parle ça fait très
longtemps que je lis beaucoup de
commentaires sur le fait que j'ai les
mains qui tremblent ça ne vous aura pas
échappé
j'ai vraiment hésité avant de vous en
parler je me suis posé beaucoup de
questions est ce que je devais vous en
parler oui non mais là je vois qu'il ya
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de questions de plus en plus en
commentaire et ça va même des fois au
delà des commentaires
mais moi dans mon entourage
professionnel pour un professionnel
j'entends par là youtube il ya des
personnes qui en parlent par derrière il
ya des personnes qui vont vous en parler
par devant et je sens qu'il ya un vrai
besoin de compréhension d'ailleurs au
delà de ça quand même un truc assez
rigolo lorsque vous googleliser une
monsieur grrrr vous allez voir dans les
suggestions tout en bas monsieur
bertrand donc vraiment des gens qui
recherchent qui veulent savoir ce qui se
passe c'est donc pourquoi j'ai décidé
aujourd'hui de vous expliquer un petit
peu ce qui se passe
[Musique]
ici par exemple je parle beaucoup de
teck
c'est le but de mes vidéos un billet non
je parle assez peu de choses perso et
aujourd'hui on va changer police pour
info on est aujourd'hui l'aéroport de
toronto retour d'audrey pluie
dominicaine il est très beau et 29
degrés
là il ya plein de neige ça caille fait
quelque chose comme - 2 - 5 mois 6
autant dire qu'il faille parfois alors
je vous parlais justement ainsi pris des
notes pour vous en parler parce que je
voulais un petit peu savoir quoi vous
dire dans quel ordre le dire parce qu'il
ya quand même beaucoup de choses à dire
cela je vois beaucoup de commentaires
beaucoup de commentaires qui me disent
que je suis trop stressé que du fait
d'être trop stressée je tremblais trop
on dit arrête le café on m'a aussi dit
que je pouvais et éventuellement manquer
de vitamine c que j'avais par kingson ou
alors carrément que je me droguais que
je prenais la cocaïne alors déjà merci à
tous ceux qui s'inquiètent réellement
que sa quatrième en pour moi l'état de
santé ça c'est très gentil mais vous
inquiétez pas ça va globalement pas trop
mal en fait je m'empresse vitamine c ou
alors en tout cas c'est pas la cause de
mon tremblements je ne vois pas de café
parce que ça met dans des états pas
possibles je suis pour pas du tout la
caféine je ne me drogue pas jamais et
c'est pas par kingson mais malgré ça
vous fait de remarquer je trempe
pour la petite histoire dans l'âge de 25
ans j'ai commencé à trembler mais
surtout de la main gauche trembloter au
début je me disais gros un peu stressé
c'est d'ailleurs comme ça que je voyais
mon entourage
un garçon hyper speed un garçon stressé
et surtout ce tremblement de la main
gauche
bourgeois disais je suis trop nerveux
c'est pour ça que je tremble ça
paraissait assez logique d'autant plus
que j'ai toujours eu un tempérament
hyper speed
j'ai toujours été hyper dynamique super
speed plein de projets et du coup
forcément ce tremblement qui arrivait
mais au bout d'un moment
malgré tout je suis allé consulter choix
y avoir un toubib pour savoir réellement
ce qui se passait d'ailleurs je pense
que ça vous aura pas échappé je suis un
garçon assez speed
je parle souvent vite et je fait
vachement garde pour canaliser sa par
exemple je peux vous dire une phrase un
peu classique ça sera voilà je suis
effectivement un peu speed et il faut
que sa tension
maintenant je vous le dis si je faisais
pas attention l'échappée speedo toute
l'attention ce qui était contre on prend
absolument rien je bouffe la moitié des
mots ça c'est un peu ma nature première
je suis extrêmement solide trop trop
speed je parle très vite du coup je suis
un peu gaffe pour descendre d'un cran
pour lui c'est vraiment le comprendre
mais malgré ça le fait d'être vide c'est
ce qui me connaît effectivement d'avoir
cette énergie est d'être dans
l'entrepreneuriat d'avoir toujours mille
projets travaille énormément
alors toujours la pêche d'ailleurs
beaucoup la pêche peut-être des fois un
peu trop la pêche
alors je vous suis donc allé voir un
neurologue qui m'a donné diagnostic en
fait j'ai une maladie que beaucoup de
personnes ont beaucoup beaucoup de
personnes et savent pas forcément
qu'elles n'ont cédé personnes qui sont
souvent prises pour des personnes trop
stressé voire même carrément des
personnes droguées ou alcooliques ce qui
peut expliquer effectivement certains
commentaires et cette maladie est connue
sous le nom de tremblement essentiel
c'est un tremblement d'actions lorsque
vous allez faire un mouvement il va y
avoir un tremblement alors la grosse
différence
une des grosses différences en tout cas
de ce que vous allez pouvoir voir par
rapport aux maladies de parkinson
maladie de parkinson c'est un
tremblement de repos quelqu'un qui a par
kingson
il a posé sa main la main il va trembler
sur un tremblement essentiel vous posez
votre main verte mal tremblay par par
contre quand vous prenez un truc dans la
main et ben forcément le truc va bouger
vous tremblez
c'est comme ça c'est un tremblement ça
arrive on peut pas contrôler ne peut pas
le maîtriser donc quand on dit arrête de
trembler je voudrais très sincèrement si
je pouvais je voudrais arrêter tremblé
mais malheureusement c'est strictement
impossible alors je tente plus de la
main gauche que de la main droite
et lorsque je suis speed stressé ce qui
est souvent le cas en tout cas très très
speed forcément le tremblement va être
accrue et lorsque j'entends des phases
de travail parce que je bosse beaucoup
je vais trouver davantage lorsque vous
êtes fatigué si encore pire enfin voilà
énervé c'est encore pire
c'est un petit peu une espèce d'escaladé
lorsque vous êtes cool vous tremblez -
mais vous tremblez quand même alors
cette maladie à tendance plutôt a évolué
qu'à un volume et donc ce qui veut dire
que normalement je devrais tremblay
toujours plus est arrivé à un certain
âge je pourrais peut-être allez savoir
sucrer les fraises alors ça pourrait
tester les téléphones ça est un peu plus
compliqué quand ça va être comme ça mais
c'est même pas sûr que ça y arrive ça
c'est une maladie dont on ne connaît pas
exactement
l'évolution ça dépend de chaque personne
c'est une maladie un caractère
héréditaire
voilà en tout cas ce que j'ai pendant
dix ans j'ai pris ça ça c'est des
bêtabloquants c'est du propranolol
havelock ardiles 80 mg on libération
prolongée 1 par jour
ça réduit tremblements ça vous pose un
petit peu vous êtes plus cool hein
attend inconvénients avec moi c'est que
ça me posais beaucoup trop il était
vraiment un état en dessous de ce que je
suis naturellement moins speed mais
moins productifs et au moins d'élan
moins envie d'y aller au bout d'un
moment j'en ai ras le cul donc au bout
de dix ans j'ai arrêté de façon un petit
peu sauvage et vraiment je ne vous le
conseille absolument pas j'ai arrêté
d'un coup normalement il ya des étapes
j'ai tout ce quiz et j'étais directement
un peu violent mais bon au final ça va
alors ce traitement marche il ya
d'autres traitements et le cas extrême
consistant
ouvrir la trappe hausse est à vous
stimulez je sais pas si c'est juste un
mois rapportent
on va passer un peu tout ça mais voilà
donc ces traitements j'ai arrêté ce qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui j'ai beaucoup de jus
beaucoup d'énergie par contre je tremble
davantage mais fondamentalement moi ça
me pose absolument aucun problème dans
la vie de tous les jours je suis en
société ça ne pose aucun problème le
fait d'avoir tremblements ça ne me
dérange absolument pas et il le fait
d'avoir des retours en termes de
commentaires ça me dérange pas non plus
je m'expose jeu c'est forcément derrière
il va y avoir des commentaires quels
qu'ils soient ces jeux je le sais ça
pose absolument aucun problème
alors pourquoi je vous parle de ça
aujourd'hui déjà une parce que je sens
derrière il ya des besoins il ya
beaucoup de personnes qui se posent des
questions admet qui s'inquiètent pour
moi donc une fois de plus je vous
remercie mais je vous le dis y'a pas de
souci j'ai un tremblement essentiel
on a tous des particularités celle là
c'est la mienne je vais trembler les
mains c'est pas grave
et advienne que pourra à l'avenir mais
je le fais également pour d'autres
personnes qui ont aussi leurs propres
particularités et à qui parfois le
regard des autres est un petit peu plus
compliqué - ça va je deviens très bien
mais il ya deux personnes pour qui c'est
plus dur donc lucas vous le dire on a
tous la particularité vous n'êtes pas
les seuls
quelles que soient les particularités la
mienne n'est pas particulièrement
invalidante aujourd'hui peut-être à
l'avenir mais pour l'instant tout cas ça
se passe plutôt pas mal donc nos soucis
là dessus en posant cette vidéo je veux
aussi peut-être à ma petite échelle
d'apporter un peu de soutien et un peu
de courage à tous ceux pour qui le
regard des autres peut être délicat en
fonction des particularités des
handicaps ou des maladies qui peuvent
avoir ma petite échelle mais moi
j'apporte un peu ma pierre à l'édifice
donc courage force et honneur
je tiens à dire que personnellement je
me plains absolument de rien je m'expose
il ya des commentaires c'est normal je
tiens néanmoins à vous donner cette
information
pas parce que j'en ai moi le besoin je
m'en serais franchement passé mais je
sens que derrière voilà comme je vous le
dis
il y a des besoins de compréhension
c'est fait c'est dieu on a parlé
maintenant on tourne la page et si vous
souhaitez en parler vous pouvez y aller
en bas en commentaires je me sens
bizarre de vous répondre
d'ici là je vous embrasse soyez sages et
là au retour à paris maintenant on un
vol dans quoi 3 4 heures 8 à 8 heures et
demie de vol
on n'est pas encore arrivé mais c'est
sympa voilà ça change et de la neige on
a passé d'excellentes vacances en
république dominicaine
en attendant je vous embrasse et à très
bientôt